MALE SPEAKER: I'd
like to introduce
Mandy Waite, our cloud developer
advocate and general cloud
miracle worker, who is
going to let you know what
what developers would
like in the cloud.
MANDY WAITE: Hey guys.
Can you all hear me?
All right.
So this is one of the
world's longest stages,
so I have to walk down
here every now and again
to say hi to you lot as well.
Hello.
So I'll try to give you
all an equal amount of love
by walking backwards
and forwards.
We are going to talk about
what our game developers are
looking for in the cloud.
So how many people
here today are
using the cloud for some part
of their application, back ends
and such like?
OK.
So we're going to cover
everything, pretty much,
the basics to what the Google
Cloud platform looks like.
And we're going to
start off like this.
So basically this is a
very quick introduction.
This is where you are.
You've developed you're game.
You've built your game.
You have, perhaps, versions of
your game for mobile platforms,
maybe for desktop as well.
You've done all of the work.
You've had a designer
go over your work,
make it really,
really attractive,
make the graphics look
fantastic, provide the best
user interaction experience
within the game itself.
You've read about
all of the lessons
that people have learned
when developing games
over the years.
You've build a beta version
and you've deployed it, maybe
to the app store, maybe
to the Google Play store,
maybe to the Chrome Web Store.
You've had zero crashes, zero
hangs, so you're done right?
That's it.
You don't have to do anymore.
But what if one of the key
features of your application
was social interaction,
the ability
to interact socially between
users of your application?
What if it was a
multi-player game?
What if you wanted it to
be a multi-player game?
What if you wanted to gather
analytics from your game
about the way people actually
interacted in your game?
One of things you might want to
do is what they did in Ingress.
How many people
have played Ingress?
This one is amazing because
we think, at Google,
that everybody plays Ingress.
But whenever I ask this
question about how many people
have played Ingress, I only
get about two hands come up.
So how many people
know what Ingress is?
Right.
OK.
So you don't play it, but
you know what it is, kind of.
So Ingress is effectively
a multi-player game.
It's more the social experience
in the game effectively.
It uses Google Maps
to show you portals
that you can go
around and capture.
There's two sides, the
united and the resistance.
You have to capture
portals or create portals.
It has great social
interaction experience.
You can talk to each
via the application.
But one of the most
important features of it
is that people get
together in groups.
They get their phones
out and they walk around
and capture portals, or
create portals together
as social groups.
This is social experience,
social interaction
at the extreme.
But obviously, how do you
build something like that?
How do you build
an application that
has those kind of services?
You can't just build
this on the phone.
There has to be some
back end component.
So how do you get
started when you're
building the back end for
a game in application?
So the first thing
you could do--
and this is what you
would have done years ago.
Maybe for some of us
now it wouldn't even
occur to us to do this.
You could actually
just build a server.
Buy a server, stick
it next to your desk.
Stick it in your garage,
stick it in your office,
and then you can run
your back end component
of your application from there.
But will it solve
all your problems?
Who installs all of the
software on this machine?
Who operates the hardware?
Who fixes the hardware
when it breaks?
What if the connection
fails to the internet?
What if there's too much load?
I'm going to talk about load
more in a couple of slides.
So these are all of
the problems you're
going to get when you're
building something
like this on a
server that you own.
And again, some of
us today probably
wouldn't even consider
this is an option.
But not so long ago, this was
pretty much the only option.
But now today we have the cloud.
This is kind of my idea.
Somebody else
provided the slide,
but this resonates
with me really well.
This is what it looked like
to build applications back
in the old days.
We used to build machines,
configure machines.
I first started with
some microsystems
in codec, working on some
microsystems machines
back in 1989.
And we used to sit
there with tapes,
loading taps into machines.
It would take a whole day
to configure a system.
We would build the hardware.
We would build the
software system.
We would build the software
stack, set up the database,
configure uses, all that stuff
we would have to do ourselves.
So you can build
all this yourself.
What about
anticipating your load?
What are you going
to build first?
How many people are
you going to get
using your
application initially?
What happens if
you get TechCrunch?
What happens if you get
slashdotted and suddenly
your load on your application
increases rapidly,
increases ridiculously
rapidly over night?
How do you handle
these kinds of spikes?
Does this have a pointer on it?
I guess not.
How do you handle traffic kind
of spikes, the kind of spike
you see here on the left,
where traffic will suddenly
increase very rapidly because
of some event that happened?
Maybe your game was published
in an article on TechCrunch
or on Slashdot or
some other key forum
for promoting
gaming applications.
What about periods
of inactivity?
What happens if your
game is kind of seasonal,
that people don't
play it all the time?
What happens if you've
over provisioned your load,
or for your load, you
have too many machines
available at any given time?
What happens when those
machines aren't being used?
You're still paying for them.
How do you handle linear scale?
How do you handle
exponential scale?
All these problems are things
you'd have to tackle yourself.
When we look at the cloud,
we see something like this.
We have these options--
infrastructure
as a service,
platform as a service,
and pretty much do it yourself.
We also talk about software
as a service and back
end as a service as well.
When you do it yourself,
you pretty much
have to do everything.
And that goes back to the
slide we looked at before
with the guy with the boxes,
building all the way up
from the operating system
up to the application level.
With infrastructure
as a service,
you get all of the
virtualization there.
You actually get
a machine provided
for you, a virtual machine.
On top of this, you install
an operating system,
usually provided by
the cloud vendor,
and on top of that can install
all the middleware, all
of the run time, and your
application software as well.
That's infrastructure
as a service.
Platform as a service is
a little bit different
because it provides the OS, the
middleware, and the run time.
It effectively provides
you with a software stack
on which you can run your
application and store data.
So which would you
choose, do it yourself,
infrastructure as a service,
or platform as a service?
We're going to explore that
question a little bit more,
shortly.
There's also back
end as a service.
Back end as a
service effectively
provides you with services that
your application can consume
directly, so things
like messaging, pub sub,
social interaction
experience, analytics,
those kinds of things.
And also you can
use gaming services,
which is what you're going
to hear about quite a lot
today from people like Daniel.
Daniel has probably already
introduced all of these
already.
So these gaming
services, you can just
plug into them very quickly.
You just write
your code to them.
You don't actually have to
build anything yourself.
So what do you choose?
Infrastructure as
a service is great.
It's particularly suited for
applications and games that
are latency sensitive,
that have a requirement
for very low latency.
And this particularly
comes into play
when you have games
like Jam with Chrome.
Anybody see Jam with Chrome,
the Chrome experiment.
So this effectively
allowed users
to get together
in an application
and play instruments,
together, interactivity,
across the world.
So one person would be
playing the drums in Australia
while another guy was
playing the guitar in the US.
And that requires
a very low latency.
That requires something
like web sockets.
So in that case,
infrastructure as a service
is perfectly suited for that
particular kind of solution.
It's also extremely flexible.
It gives you the
most flexibility
of all of the solutions
possible because you
can build anything
you like with it.
It's a virtual machine.
You can also reuse all of that
code and database knowledge
that you've built
up over the years.
You don't have to worry
about abstractions.
Anybody who's
working for you who
knows how to program a
database, how to actually build
a software stack, you can
reuse all of that knowledge.
I-A-A-S-- IaaS-- is particularly
suited for complex games.
You can pretty much run
anything you like on it.
But if you have a
really complex game,
it may be the other
offerings, the other solutions
are not particularly
suitable for you.
When it comes to
platform as a service,
the sweet spot for
and we'll look at
App Engine shortly,
is the handling of scale,
the ability to handle scale.
Those kinds of
loads we looked at
before where we have
huge spikes in traffic,
we have levels where
we're not actually
using any resources at all.
We have exponential
growth, or linear growth.
Platform as a service is also
great for providing services
to allow for player
to player interaction.
So again, this goes
back to Ingress.
Ingress runs on a
platform as a service,
and it offers all of
these features to you.
It will make it very easy to
access other APIs and services
to allow you to build
social interaction.
Spiking use numbers
comes back to scale.
This is pretty good for
casual types of games.
Games like Ingress.
Then you have these
gaming services.
Flappy Bird.
I'm not sure if I'm
allowed to use this icon,
but it was on here
when I got the slide.
How many people have
played Flappy bird.
OK.
You admit it at least.
One of the key things
about Flappy Bird
is not the game play.
We must admit the game
play in Flappy Bird is not
the best in the world.
But it does have this
wonderful social interaction
in that you can see your
friends' high scores.
That service is very,
very simple to set up.
Once you have your
high score, you
can see your
friends high scores,
and you can compare
your scores with theirs,
and then try to beat it.
And that's where you start
playing it over, and over,
and over again.
Until the point where are throw
your phone across the room
because you keep hitting a pipe.
It's very easy to get started
with these kinds of services,
and it offers things like
high scores and achievements.
It offers you the ability
to go back to your device
and play the game, put the
device down, pick up a tablet,
pick up some other offering
and play that game,
picking up from where you
left off within the gaming
environment as before.
Sorry.
This is very good for
very simple games.
Although you can build quite
complex games with it as well.
So this comes back to Ingress.
Ingress was built on what's
known as App Engine, Google App
Engine, this is part
of our cloud platform.
The social experience
that Ingress offers
is very, very important to it.
Platform as a
service was key here.
The ability to handle
the kind of scale
that the game of Ingress'
size-- again although nobody
seems to be playing it.
It's quite hard to know
whether it actually
needs to scale up
to huge levels.
So Ingress is built on top
of platform as a service.
Here's a quick quiz for you.
Which company offers traditional
hosting, infrastructure
as a service in
the cloud, platform
as a service in the cloud,
and back end as a service,
and mobile platform
as a service?
That's us.
We offer all of those services.
Again, I think you're going to
go over all these today quite
a number of times.
You're going to see
this kind of circle.
things like Admob
The Android Play game services.
Chrome Web Store.
More Play Services.
Admob double click exchange.
Google Cloud platform analytics.
These are all of the
things we offer in order
to build up our
gaming experience.
So let's talk about the
Google Cloud Platform.
How many people here
have actually heard
of the Google Cloud platform?
How many people have
actually used it?
OK.
So the Google Cloud platform
is pretty much a new idea.
We started off with App
Engine back in 2008.
Since then we've made
available Compute Engine,
another component of
our cloud platform.
And we're booting
up other services
on top of that to make a
comprehensive, integrated,
complete cloud platform.
Let's go over what that
actually looks like.
Well first a bit of history.
Software innovation happens
quite rapidly at Google.
Back in 2002 we had a
requirement for a file system
that was extremely fast,
extremely scalable, and very
low maintenance for our
engineers, something
they could just
throw data at and not
have to worry about it too much.
So we built this thing
called Google File System.
On top of that we
built MapReduce.
We published a paper.
All of these are white papers.
The MapReduce runs on top
of Google File System.
It allows us to run analytics
across data fairly quickly.
Then we had BigTable.
BigTable is another
[INAUDIBLE] offering,
which we built on top
of Google File System.
And which is now available as
the Google Cloud data store.
Effectively, this is what
App Engine, our platform
as a service offering,
was built around.
Then in 2008 we published a
white paper on an application
called Dremel, which
we use internally.
What this came about from
was the need of our product
managers to be able to
ask questions of data
very, very quickly, to get
answers back interactivity
effectively, to be able to
answer questions interactively
and get answers back in seconds,
instead of minutes or hours.
Ultimately we wrote
this tool called Dremel,
and we published it since then
as BigQuery, Google BigQuery.
How many people have
heard of BigQuery?
OK, so we should
have a conversation
about what BigQuery
is because it's
extremely important
for analytics
and gaining insight into
what your data looks like.
Beyond that, we came up
with Google File System
two, which is called Colossus.
And on top of that, Google
Cloud Storage was built on.
Cloud storage we'll
talk about shortly,
but that is our bucket store.
It's an object store for large
amounts of unstructured data.
We're talking about pretty much
any amount of data you like,
up to five terabytes an object.
Then we have Spanner/F1.
F1 is it's internal name.
It was published as a
white paper called Spanner.
This should be
[INAUDIBLE] on the cloud.
And then finally Omega,
which is a task orchestrator.
So if anybody's ever
heard of Borg internally,
at Google we use this term Borg.
It's leaked out several times.
But we have this thing called
Omega now, "Omeega," Omega.
I'm not quite sure
how to say it.
I've spent too much
time in the US.
Omega, which is a
task orchestrator,
a very, very advanced feature
that we've introduced recently
and which has a white
paper backing it.
Then the Google
Cloud Platform itself
consists of three main areas.
They are compute,
storage, and app services.
On the compute side, we look
at these in more detail,
we have App Engine,
and Compute Engine.
Then on the storage side
we have Cloud Storage,
which I've just mentioned.
Which is built on
top of Colossus,
and that again provides
a bucket storage service
for storing unstructured data.
Cloud SQL offers you MySQL
instances in the cloud.
These are completely
fully managed instances.
So you create your
database on an instance.
You create your tables
within the database,
but you don't have to
worry about managing
the actual instance itself.
Then we have the
Cloud Datastore,
which is our massively
scalable, automatically
scalable, NoSQL offering.
This, again, used to be tied
completely to App Engine.
App Engine was effectively built
around the Cloud Datastore,
but now it's
available as an API.
And this is perfect
for structured data,
or semi-structured data, and
it doesn't require a schema.
It effectively uses
buckets of properties.
Then we have application
services such as BigQuery,
and I mentioned BigQuery before.
But imagine the need for
running analytics very quickly
across your data, either
running interactively
or through an API.
BigQuery is effectively
an API, but it
has a console that you can
use to interactively query
your data.
It runs very, very fast.
It has an SQL like
syntax, and can
run across terabytes
of data in seconds,
billions of rows of data.
Then we have Cloud
implants, which
will expand on more, which
effectively allows you to build
APIs, your interface
into the Cloud.
So some of these Cloud
platform features
that we feel are
important to call out here
are the ability to scale,
you want your app to scale,
you want it to scale
to Google scale,
the ability to scale
very quickly on demand.
And scaling here,
we're talking about
not just the ability
to scale upwards
to manage spikes in traffic,
but also to remove resources
when they're not needed.
So do you have what you
need when you need it,
but you only pay
for what you use.
Also, because of the
ability to auto scale,
you don't actually have to
plan ahead for resources.
When we use App Engine, we'll
look App Engine again shortly,
App Engine will scale up
and speed up instances
as required to meet the
demand from the traffic
to your application.
Also flexible charging.
Again, we go back to
what we said before,
pay for only what you use.
And this is quite
important to anybody
developing applications
in the Cloud.
If you have resources sitting
around consuming cost,
that's down to you.
But if you're having to pay for
things that you're not using,
say you use a virtual machine
for 10 minutes, 20 minutes,
and you pay for an hour instead
of just those 20 minutes
you're using the
virtual machine,
then that's not very
efficient for you.
Also no large scale investments.
You don't actually
have to buy machines,
you don't have to buy a big
cluster of machines or boxes,
you don't have to
build a database.
And we have these start up
programs that are available.
Start up packs.
A very simple start up program.
Did you all get the little card?
Yeah?
I think Rupert is going
to talk more about later,
but effectively that
gives you some credit you
can use for the Google
Cloud platform itself.
Then we have these RESTful APIs
and the ability to integrate
with other Google services at
effectively what is very low
latency interactions with Google
services such as YouTube, Maps,
Google+ APIs, and other services
such as the Cloud data store,
Cloud storage, all the other
services we looked at before.
Also these APIs are supported
by many third party tools,
and we provide tools as
well for building APIs.
And these are very
consistent and standardized
across all of our product range.
When it comes to support, we
have free and paid support
options.
And our support team
has real engineers.
So effectively what we have
are site reliability engineers,
and I'll talk more
about those in a second.
And we have a free nines
SLA for all of our products.
So let's talk about App Engine.
App Engine, again, the
ability to auto scale.
We've covered this already so I
won't go into any more detail.
It's very easy to get started
with Google App Engine.
It's free to start.
There's a free tier.
You don't have to
put your credit card
information or any
billing information in.
Effectively, you get some
quotas you can use for a day.
They get reset on a daily basis.
And that's really good
to get started with.
Also we provide you with a
local development environment,
so you can do all of your
development interactively
on your own workstation,
or on your laptop,
before deploying new
applications to App Engine.
It also offers the service
abstraction, abstractions
to the Cloud
Datastore, to Memcache.
They're very easy
to get started with.
You don't actually have
to build Memcache service.
Memcache is available
to you directly.
We have abstractions that allow
you to access the data store
very, very easily
within your code.
It's also extremely
trivial to manage.
So App Engine is fully managed.
It provides software
stacks in the cloud.
Currently we support
Python, Java, PHP, and Go.
Low patches.
You don't have to worry
about patching or upgrading
these software run times.
And they are
operated 24/7 by what
we call site
reliability engineers.
These are the guys
that wear the pagers.
that get woken up
at two AM in the morning to
fix issues with App Engine.
Then cloud endpoints.
I've mentioned Cloud
endpoints briefly already.
Cloud endpoints allows you to
expose your application code
as an API.
What you do is you write
your application code,
deploy it to App Engine, you
can then add some annotations
to your code, or you can
build this all from scratch.
Add some annotations to your
code, deploy it to App Engine
again, and you will
effectively have
APIs running on the Google
infrastructure, the Google API
infrastructure that we use
for exposing our own APIs.
These APIs are
completely discoverable.
They're RESTful APIs, and
they're very, very easy to use.
Once you have the API exposed,
you can use [INAUDIBLE].
It's available from Android
studio Eclipse from the command
line to build client
libraries, which can then
be consumed by
your applications,
either Android,
iOS, or JavaScript.
All this comes with built-in
authentication support,
so it's very, very
easy to use in terms
of authenticating users.
Cloud Endpoints look
something like this.
It's very, very simple to use.
You'll start off.
This could be brand new code
or it could be something
you've exposed already
to web based users,
and now you want to
expose it as an API that
can be consumed directly from
another application service.
So in this case we have a
method called Submit answers,
and we've annotated it with a
method called at API method.
Here we're actually saying we
want to use HTTP method put.
Some of these things can be
inferred by the run time.
If we call this method insert
answer, or something like that,
then we could infer that
that would be a put.
So get answers would
also be inferred
that would be a get method.
But we can specifically
say is in the annotation.
It has very, very standard
defaults that it works with.
You can also specify the path.
Again, that could also be
inferred by the class name,
by the method name.
In this case the
path is game/id,
id is a parameter
which we're going
to call out later,
slash answers.
That will be the path
for our RESTful call.
So submit answers
is our method, it
takes a couple of parameters,
three in this case, a game id
answers and a user
object called player.
We've annotated the
game id with a name
D id to give it a
name, effectively.
And that's used in the-- I
wish this had a pointer on it.
And that's used in the path
in the original API method
declaration.
The user object itself
is injected into the call
by the run time.
It's not something
you need to provide.
So when this method is invoked
by a user that's already
logged into Google,
the logged in user
will be injected into that
call, into that API call.
Then we can actually check to
see if the user is logged in.
If the user recall is
no, we can throw out
an unauthorized exception
saying this user is not
authorized to use this method.
Effectively it would require it
to be logged in at that point.
Then we can call
gameservice.submitanswers,
which is some other abstraction
we've built somewhere else.
When it comes to actually
calling this method
from within an
Android application,
we would build a client
library from this code.
It's very easy to do.
There's [INAUDIBLE], as
I say, in Android Studio.
You can just say build
Cloud Endpoints client
library, same
thing with Eclipse.
And once you have that, you
can build your application
around that client library.
And effectively,
what you would do
is you would call
service.gameendpoint.
That would give you give
you the endpoint itself,
but you can consume
within the application,
and then you'd call
submit answers on that.
So service.gameendpoint
effectively represents
the client library, the
[INAUDIBLE] client library
which will make the
call to the API.
And in terms of tooling, that
looks something like this.
This is a little
bit out of date now,
but we have tools
in the command line.
We have this tool
called G Cloud,
the cloud SDK that can call
out these methods for you.
And here, on the top line,
we see the client library
being generated.
And you can also do the
same thing with an Eclipse
and with an Android Studio.
Compute Engine offers virtual
machines and block storage
in the Cloud.
It also offers low
balance in the networking.
All of the compute
resources you need
to build clusters in machines.
And there's going to be some
announcements today that
are actually going to put
a new spin on this as well.
It's also cost effective.
A sub hour billing.
You only pay for--
You pay always
for 10 minutes of your usage
of the virtual machine,
but beyond 10 minutes you
only pay by the minute.
So if you use a virtual
machine for 15 minutes,
you'll pay for 15
minutes, not for an hour.
That's extremely cost efficient.
We also do not charge IOPS
charges for block storage.
Every machine needs
block storage.
Every virtual machine
needs block storage,
and we do not charge for IOPS
to you block storage devices.
So you effectively just
pay by the terabyte.
And we don't need to
provide virtual machines
for load balancing.
Load balancing is
actually effectively built
into our network infrastructure.
It's also consistently fast.
We have very fast
instance provisioning.
We can bring up 1,000 virtual
machines in under two minutes.
I was going to do
a demo of this,
but decided not to because
we have this big event going
on today, and if I did something
that inadvertently caused
our cloud platform some
issues I would probably
get it in the neck.
So I'm not going to do the demo.
Normally we do this demo that
shows 1,000 machines being spun
up in about one minute 30
seconds, one minute 45 seconds.
Consistent disk performance is
extremely important as well,
because if you run an
application in the Cloud
you want to avoid this
noisy neighbor problem.
You want to avoid the
operations that somebody else is
performing affecting yours.
So we have very consistent
disk performance.
Also our Cloud native load
balancing requires no warm ups.
Most load balancing services
require a warm up period.
Ours is instantly on.
As soon as you start using it,
it will be available to you.
A Google BigQuery, we talked
about that quite a bit
already, but effectively
import data into BigQuery.
Once you had the data
imported into BigQuery
you can run queries
interactively
or fire an API across that data.
And that allows you to
ask important questions
of the data.
If it's gaming data
you're looking at,
you could be interested in
things like daily active users.
What is the user doing?
How is the user interacting
with the application?
What can I do?
What actions can I take
in order to improve
the experience for the
user, for the player?
And what you would do
is you would constantly
run these analytics
on a daily basis,
getting graphs and
charts, automatic based
analysis of these interactions.
Sending them offers
and such like
at certain points in
their user experience
to try to get to
use the game more.
It's extremely affordable.
You'll see more
about this later.
First 100 gigabytes
per month are free.
We have a very
simple pricing model,
and we have a validator that
tells you the size of a query
when you run it,
so you can actually
predict how much
a query will cost.
It's extremely easy to use, it's
built for scaling performance.
Very simple SQL queries.
And it has open interfaces
for REST and JDBC.
In terms of what we're
going to announce
today, is something
called Manage vMs.
This has been available in
[INAUDIBLE] for some time now.
It used to be
called vM run times.
What we're trying to
do here is to blur
the lines between infrastructure
as a service and platform
as a service, so it's no
longer a binary choice for you.
So you don't
actually have to make
a choice between infrastructure
or platform as a service.
You can choose one and a
move towards the other.
This is facilitated
by this thing called
manage virtual machines,
which effectively allows
you to use App Engine
as your front end
but to use Compute Engine
virtual machines as back ends.
Back end modules effectively
of your application
that can run anything you like.
So we talked about
platform as a service,
App Engine we know to run
Go, Java, PHP, and Python.
But what happens if you
want to run node.js.
So you can run that on
infrastructure as a service,
on Compute Engine, but
still have App Engine manage
those virtual machines for you.
So that's effectively blurring
the lines between platforms
as a service and
infrastructure as a service.
So again, going
into more details
about how you would choose,
infrastructure as a service
has its sweet spots,
compute workloads,
or do MapReduces,
those kinds of things.
Running simulations, running
Monte Carlo simulations,
running complex workloads.
Platform as a service is
great for game back ends,
mobile back ends, web
type workloads, things
where load is unpredictable
where you require auto scaling.
Both of them work brilliantly
for background processing.
You can do background processing
with platform as a service,
or with infrastructure
as a service.
But when it comes to things
like running node.js,
you need V to access
your virtual machines.
You have C++ libraries
you want to run,
you want to run web sockets,
then you're going to need
to move to infrastructure
as a service.
So manage virtual machines
allows you to do both
and fills in that gap
between infrastructure
as a service and
platform as a service.
So a complex app architecture
would look something like this.
We have all these
services at the top here
which are App Engine services.
The Datastore, Memcache, we
have things like task queues,
full search API, mail
service, Cloud storage API.
Then we have modules.
We have two App Engine modules.
And App Engine is
completely modular now.
We have two App Engine modules,
service and web traffic.
These are auto scale modules.
They have the ability to auto
scale to meet user demand.
But over here we also
have another module,
which is a vM based back end
module, a managed vM model
that we built using the
infrastructure as a service
virtual machines.
That gives us full access
to the App Engine APIs,
but it gives us full control
of the virtual machines.
There's just one thing
I want to mention.
I added this slide
at the last minute
because I realized
I left it out.
It's the ability to
do vM orchestration.
So App Engine can manage
infrastructure as a service
virtual machines
directly through an API.
So Compute Engine
itself has its own API.
We can use App Engine to spin
up new instances on demand,
effectively to managing
auto scale for us.
So if we have a game
that requires back
end gaming service, we need
to provision more service
as the load increases.
Then we can use vM
orchestration on App Engine
to actually fire up new servers,
new game servers, on demand.
In this case, the example
shows a heartbeat process
with DVM orchestration service
actually checking the heartbeat
process, looking at how busy
that particular server is,
and making decisions on
when to spin up new servers
or when to bring servers down.
This is a reasonably
complicated architecture,
and it's one sample
application we
have published on
cloud.google.com.
Again, in terms
of gaming we have
all of these amazing studios
using our cloud platform,
including Rovio, Gamesys,
Chillingo, and also Song Pop.
So Song Pop basically
built their game
with just three or four
developers on a project.
They didn't need to worry about
building an infrastructure.
They're now up to one
million daily plays already.
Well, they were up to 1
million daily players already
at two weeks after launch.
Now I think they're
at about 2.4 million.
They serve effectively
about 18 terabytes a day
to 80 million users.
There was a talk, I/O
2013 talk, Google Air,
called intense gaming that
went into this in more detail.
In order to get started with
the Google Cloud Platform,
it's completely free
for using App Engine.
We can give you
credits for startups,
if you're a startup we
can give you credit packs.
Documentation and
tutorials are available
on developers.google.com.
In this case it's just
for App Engine itself.
If you're interested
in the starter pack,
you have the little cards.
You can claim those credits
and use that code there,
dsummit-con.
That's it.
So I think we're out
of time for questions.
So if you want to
catch me at lunch time
if you have any
questions-- yeah?
You sure?
OK.
Yeah.
So, any questions?
AUDIENCE: Can we grab the
microphones for questions,
because they're being
recorded as well.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have your service
running in China as well?
MANDY WAITE: Running in China?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MANDY WAITE: Well, I don't think
we have a data center in China.
We have a data center in Taiwan.
AUDIENCE: It might be
an opportunity then.
MANDY WAITE: Is that something
you're interested in?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MANDY WAITE: So you have
game users in China?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
Right.
So what are you using currently?
AUDIENCE: We're building
up our own infrastructure.
MANDY WAITE: You're building
up your own infrastructure.
AUDIENCE: Amazon has
said that they're
doing something
in China as well,
but they're working
with local services,
so it's not the same as
what they do in the West.
It's actually trying to find
out together with Chinese people
and trying to mirror
what we have over here.
It's a huge cost to build
up your own data center.
It's a lot of work
we shouldn't be
doing because we
need to create games.
MANDY WAITE: So again, maybe
watch for announcements today
at the live event to see
what we're going to announce,
but we don't have any data
centers in China at the moment.
You're right.
It's a huge place,
and it would be
great to have data
centers there,
but maybe there are some
concerns about security
and such like as well.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thanks.
MANDY WAITE: Cheers.
Any more questions?
OK.
Right.
One more.
AUDIENCE: I was interested to
hear a bit more about the auto
scaling that you
mentioned, which
was about scaling
up and conversely
scaling down on demand.
Can you run through that
again, because that's
what's most interesting to us.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
So when it comes to
App Engine, App Engine
has this thing called auto
scale, the ability to auto
scale, based on a very
complicated algorithm,
effectively able
to monitor traffic.
When a new request
comes in, it will say,
do I have an instance available
to service that request?
Do I have a parameter set in
called pending queue latency
that will tell me how
long that request should
sit in the queue?
If it's going to sit
in the queue for longer
than that time, based
on my algorithm,
I can spin up a new instance
to service that request.
But then maybe there's
an issue, maybe
it takes too long to
spin up an instance.
So you have these things
called idle instances
as well that can
service requests
that can't be serviced
by an instance currently.
So effectively what we have is
the algorithm that will spin up
instances on demand,
will queue requests
for a given amount of time,
based on your parameters,
and we have idle
instances that can
be used to service requests
that can't be serviced
by anything else very quickly.
So that's effectively
how auto scale works.
The instances come
up very quickly,
and they scale down
very quickly as well.
There's no timeout period.
We look constantly on the
load, on the machines,
on their pending queues
on each instance.
And if we see that there's
no jobs queued for them,
we'll tear them down once
the current job is finished.
So it's very efficient.
We have the ability to
scale up very quickly
and to scale down
very quickly as well.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
Cool.
OK.
So good.
Thank you, Rich.
Thanks for the time.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks
very much, Mandy.